hello everyone my name is Kim Cuong I'm
a few application scientists from MGI
subsidiary group from B Jie GU so today
I am going to talk about our DN b
microbial detection platform and
explaining a few cases from our
sequencing users showing how they use
our total solution to enable in my
computer I dent application so first of
all I would like to thank you
lapwood inviting me and our company to
give this presentation so today's
webinar is going to be divided into four
parts first I wouldn't be introduced b j
and m ja history and our DN basic
technology second part will go for the M
Sharma computer solution and the third
part I discussed about how BFI or
bacterial fuss identification works and
the case study for MIT and the final
part will be an under PI informatics
solution which is a pathogen fast
identification system all PFI so as you
may have a PGI Beijing genomics
Institute it is established in 1999
representing China to contribute of one
percent of the human genomic project
after that we decided to chop the name
page in genomics Institute shortened as
PGI
over the last 20 years we have been
making a tremendous contribution to a
different human genome project for
example in 2002 we contribute 10% to the
international hapmap project and we
contribute the first Asian genome
project 1,000 children project and just
last year we published a Chinese
population scale genomics study with
140,000 genome so the key point or the
key technology of BTI group
rely on people and the technology which
is coming from MTR in 2014 DJ group
acquired
Complete Genomics and three years after
that mg is established so this year is
2019 and you can tell within only three
years we have been going but early for
now we have over
900 employee across the wall or 40% are
in these people and several hundred
pattern in MGR as well so far we have
more than 300 user and more than a
thousand a hundred sequencer so you may
wonder why the the sequencing usage
choose our sequencer because we offer a
different sequencing technology so the
sequencing technology from MGR is called
en bici so the MVC stands for DNA
Ngunnawal sequencing the core of this
tnbc technology is actually boring
circle amplification or RCA for short so
what it means for our CA is that in a
regular cases you make a sequencing
library say you stop on DNA or on a
sample and you make it and prepare and
a-telling at the adapter and you make
you PCL or you don't do PCR and there is
some further follow up with some
purification and then you're good to go
with a double strand linear 4-piece
library in our case which is quite
different with the nature the double
strand library that you may into single
strand and circularize it so as you can
see here we have the single strand
summarized DNA circle with this circle
we use 529 primaries to replicate many
many copy from the original template so
you can see here one compete you can't
be all the way until 300 to 500 copy
so all this copied is coming from the
original template and so this one
sinkholes single strand circle become
fun free DNA nanopore
in the Eppendorf tube so you may wonder
why we needed to take an extra step to
make DMB or single strand DNA library
this is because try to imagine if you
only have one circle it's more like one
match and then you have the weak or low
intensity from the sequencer and in
situation we make our ca we make a DNA
none of all format so it become 500 -
500 coffee so it's more like a palm
power that's why the signal or the
intensity is much higher and then you
may wonder we could have just done it
with PCR just like any other sequencer
in the market been doing but there might
be problems as you may know the PCR
steps in the sequencer for example it
may indeed use force SNP it may
introduce force in doubt they might have
come first bias as well or GC buyers and
if you're dealing with many many sample
in one sequencing one you might have of
the problem of index hopping like saying
the sequencing with was aligned it with
another sample which should have come
from sample from the first one with our
DN be sick technology and the RCA
reaction we offer a different feature
format so you may know this is a linear
amplification and there will be really
low and the kitchen buyers and because
of the way that we amplify the original
coffee
there's no application of the corn or
error say if you make like a mistake
from one copy the next copy that you
generate we're still coming from the
original copy and because of these we
have much lower index hopping waiting so
DNA none aboard EMB is just part of the
DN basic technology we also have the
pattern away and the C part sequencing
technology altogether in this DN BC
technology we can achieve higher
sequencing accuracy better or lower
second decrease duplication wait and we
also have a lower and actually much
lower index hopping where you compare to
other people so we bring all this
advantage from the d NB c-- technology
to our engine my computable total
solution so when we talk about microbial
detection there are cheap options for it
one on the right hand side is your
isolate and counter the bacterial
followed by 16s sequencing or using the
batch
whole genome sequencing or WGS for short
- to the idea of this is to detect or
monitor trace the source of the disease
and improve the prevention and the
control system and the other option as
the metagenomic sequencing so in fact
more than 99% of the micro organism in
nature then not be able to culture or
purify under the lab condition and this
type of sample in order the sequence
that you have to use this culture female
sample to perform the method genomic
sequence and so that we can identify the
unknown microbial infection from it so
with MGI
we offer a series of product starting
from the original samples a broad thesis
froze one CSL for others come and sample
that you know we could do Mannering
manually DNA or on extraction format we
can also do automation to automatically
extract the RNA or DNA fragment and as I
just mentioned there are two options you
can go for a single bacterial or the
methods methods genomic sample so on the
right hand side a single bacterial
sample you could prepare a DNA library
using our kids followed by the
sequencing and the bioinformatics
solution that we offer on the left hand
side the metagenomic sequencing options
they have the possible way to do it you
can only say extract the DNA from a that
prepare library from it or you could
only work on RNA or you could work on
both so RNA and DNA in combination to
actively are to detect those actively
expressed pathogen so after viewing the
library or the DNA or RNA the next step
as you may know is go for sequencing if
you have many sample and you want to
have a lower-cost format you might
consider our I'm sure I said 2000 which
is a desktop sequencer if you have a
lower food port and you want to aim for
faster the detection mesa then rmz are
six 200 which is also a desktop
sequencer maybe
good for you so artist sequencing which
depends on the riddlin may take one or
two days to generate the fast kill file
you could use this file path cue file to
connect it to our bioinformatics
workstation or server so there are two
system here for the data analysis of
bioinformatics solution one is the
bacterial classification system we call
BFI for short the second one is the
pathogen fast identification system of
PFR so the difference between BFI and
PFI is that if you want to look at
single bacteria then you might consider
BFI and you can do your sequencing with
the BFI system to detect the zero type
look at the evolutionary accessibility
Java system gene identification and etc
say if you have a metal sample and this
is something that cannot be cultured you
might want to consider our PFI system
conversion faster die so average and
fast identification system they're good
for Bronx to folks well as I mentioned
and under sample that you will come to
trial and these application is suitable
for infection that caused by unknown
pathogen and I'm going to give some
example in the later slide and so for
the PFI system is really good for
Research Hospital CDC Center of this is
control and cause order so let's talk
about the BFI system so BFI is a
biomimetic system after you you're
sequencing one you pop it in into your
poem for medics workstation with only
one quick to tell okay this is the
sequencing one that we just is please
identify the species format and we're
feeling really short time you give you a
genome
identification before which look like
that the first section is about the
basic information and the section
section will give you the persistent
gene from the sequencing one the next
section on the Y is the identification
of rear-engine and fourth power which is
the one I really like is to tell you the
position of your sample in a
phylogenetic tree
and the feed part we will give you the
analysis of potential outbreak as an
example here on the left-hand side of
red square here is the disease outbreak
that happens in 2007 and the on the
white hand side is another outbreak that
happened in 2012 so if you want to make
a comparison between next generation
sequencing and the traditional method
which could be a PFG pattern so pfg is
pulsed field gel electrophoresis so here
is the comparison so the upper part is
the protocol or steps from PFD G let's
assume that you stopped from day one and
8 a.m. so first of all you make a gel
which indicates here is the wet bar
looking at is the manual operation step
that you need to look at and the green
part is some sort of water bath or let
the Machine won-lang without hands on as
you can tell it go for many many stuff
from the lab to white until dates you to
get the gel one day overnight and then
you look at the Whistle compare the
patterns and you might get the result in
the afternoon of day 2 which is one fee
30 also there in the case for NGS you're
looking at let's assume that you also
start from day one at 8:00 a.m. you
start on preparation of your DNA sample
and going for optimation pipe like the
first phase and then quantification and
the second phase with that you can send
a sample to sequencing on it's the same
day and the next day early morning
because you're connected to the
bioinformatic workstation as well and
that's why heat generated we sell
automatically so pretty much on dates
you when you come back for world you get
the results or which is like 5:00 a.m.
in the morning I assume that you saw at
a a.m. so with that you can tell the
time is shorter it's like several hours
further which might be critical for your
case not just a time is shorter but also
the hands-on
is less so you can tell the wet bar here
and in the pfg he situation and wet bar
here in the NGS situation also not just
the time and the room for less era also
it's about - that you could go with NGS
kissable pfg ii like 10 or 15 rolls that
you could know but with NGS system you
could actually put several replicate and
many many patient sample in one
sequencer here with mt i see 200 so with
all this advantage is trying to
out-compete the traditional method with
our MJ microbial total solution as a
real case using BFI system so this is a
cases not published a hospital in China
use our B emphasis use our MGM a copy of
Toto solution with the BFI system first
of all the culture there Mycobacterium
tuberculosis sample on the first day the
orange park here in the circle and the
next day so at the same day they
prepared RNA DNA library format and then
going for the sequencer which took 48
hours in this case followed by the
bioinformatics solution and in the air
they were able to identify on the MTB
compacts from other of microbial micro
bacteria from the clinical sample not
just that they and they can actually
detect 15 job with systems in here from
the table of a kind of jerk and these
table actually really help them to guide
the clinical tuberculosis therapy so the
second case is about a public health
issue here which is published in 2017 so
gentlemen we're turning from Angola to
China showing some symptoms related to
we've got a fever and the hospital
decided to do a whole genome sequencing
for me to identify the rehab the
isolation so what they do is they going
through my copy of total solution
platform for by BFI so what it does a
secretary
is to taking the sequencing wall data
which is depicted on the right hand side
here running for the by automatic
pipeline by itself to classify the virus
to identify the subtype and to assemble
the genome and they also look at a whole
bunch of things that will be reported in
the in the report which includes
evolutionary analysis size polymorphism
distribution and key size analysis so
the result is that they actually have
like a hundred percent alignment of this
are we FBI so they they call our we have
the isolate from Beijing because this is
where it comes from and they have a
hundred percent identity of V gene
segments and 98 percent homologous to
our we have V isolate in South Africa
so as you can see our my computo
solution really have this public health
issue to monitor or actually prevent the
disease outbreak now we move on to
discuss the PFI system on the pathogen
fast identification system so PFI system
is another PI informatics software for
for total solution perform so what it
does is two one for the pipeline and
then generate a report to help you to
identify the my copy of genome sequence
from the original sample is a fully
automatic work for it generate the
report within six hour once you get
start it include a huge database it also
gives you a comprehensive analysis where
these data is coming from RNA or DNA
singular and no pattern so this is how
PFR works opted sequencing wall danger
is that to remove the low quality data
or the adapter sequence from the
original sequencer it also we move the
house data because if you've done like a
better genomic sequencing there are high
percentage of the sample could come from
the house which could be human or animal
we have the rest
from the database so that it can remove
the host genome weather is coming from
human or animal so after the removal of
those host data the level that the level
where data will be going for the
database for analysis so in the database
that are close to 20,000 microbial
species that they need to analyze in the
software and after doing all this
alignment and analysis you generate a
report that contain QC we saw also a
summary of the classification of RNA and
DNA data and the identification program
so this is not something early or
premature actually there have been four
so three thousand and four hundred
clinical sample have internet and test
with our sequencing platform and the
total solution as you can see here on
the right hand side is the distribution
or percentage of the Bilco time over 70%
75% of the sample come from DNA and the
remaining 25% also come from the RNA
sample and on the left hand side is the
pie chart of the sample and disease
there are over 13 type of sample that
our sequencing user have child for
example plasma supernatant bacterial
strain sputum cobra etc and in terms of
disease they were able to detect a
series of this is from from all this
sample as well for example the most
common one will be in Forenza Samoa no
infection and with the system they will
also be able to attack say AIDS or Zika
virus infection so this is another
sample coming from CDC center of Disease
Control from China there was a day the
CDC received a true sample from a
patient that potentially infected when
the cross border this particular patient
of passenger was suffering from diarrhea
so the DC DC decided to do metagenomic
sequencing with the sample so what they
did exactly is to collect a sample on
the first day which is there is no soul
child for thee they started beauty in
the extraction and library construction
with our automation system the same day
followed by the sequencing one the same
day and in the next day they shoot at
2:30 p.m. in the afternoon they were
able to identify the pathogen so on the
bottom left side is the pie chart and a
slap shot from the PFI report over 44
percent of forty four point three
percent of the sequencing won't come
from the coli in fact a at some point
that the CDC cannot identify the office
pathogen on speed sweep species level so
they keep searching our PFI database
they specifically they search the rarest
gene database and they were able to
identify thermostable and the toxin gene
in those eco life and that's why they
inverted this particular patient was
actually infected by ET e CI and throw
toxin a coli and this missile actually
was consistent with that of culture in
case number four is about the diagnosis
of animal disease so our p fi system not
only can identify the pathogen for human
we can also identify potential pathogen
from animal so this example is not
published yet but basically a group of
goals they were infected with unknown
pathogen with a series of symptoms our
sequencing user decided to talk their
first one followed by our approach and
fast identification photo solution in
particularly look at the DNA and RNA
sample at the same time before
automation system going through the
pipeline sample path library sequencing
one and paramedics pipeline and in the
end a report is generated within two
days so these are steps of the report on
the white hand side the first one not
sure if you can see it but i pointed out
is actually all virus which is quite
common in a gulf
based on the sequencing read from both
DNA and RNA so 64 20 percent of the
DNA's data mapped it back to this virus
and 44 percent of the RNA map it back to
that virus and based on the knowledge
that they have they can tell these
symptoms that group of grow had actually
matching the symptoms from this of
Marvis contamination and of course the
we saw was further compounded by PCR
later
so this PFI system really have user to
diagnose the animal deceased the next
case case five is about the diagnosis of
where pathogen so last year on August 20
a gentleman was sent to hospital he has
a series of symptoms Sofia had a high
fever our level of the CSF leukocyte
protein level and a day after that is
getting worse and he was sent into ICU
intensive intensive intensive center
units and they have a CT scan result for
him getting some symptoms from the brain
as well
four days after they took the CSF sample
from the culture and the result from the
culture suggests it was negative for
bacteria and function so it has been
almost like 11 days now and they went
for all this traditional effort and they
have problem identify the root cause of
this infection and in the end and the
hospital decided to use our MGI a copy
of photo solution in particular on
August 31st which is 11 day after that
they took the sample warning for the
type of pipeline from MGI and we were
able to generate or we put two days
after that so here's here's the report
in on the right hand side the bottom
white is a purple pie chart format so
the purple part which have come for
around 92% the
sequencing one coming from the holes
which is human and the smallest lie of
that pipe is the long host data if you
make it back you can tell the Queen pipe
on the right hand side and that tiny bit
of slide on the queen is actually the
sequencing with coming from this really
rare pathogen which account for only
zero points you two six six percent of
the sequencing one from his sample so
after studying of this bacteria or
pathogen hospital staff were able to
identify actually this might be the
cause of this infection and that all
happened after 13 days so basically my
point is that they spent 11 days with
the traditional method and they fail to
detect the pathogen and with the
sequencing wonder that we provide it
only takes two days for them and they
were able to identify the pathogen so if
they first decided to go for my copy of
total solution within two days they
might find identify the where pathogen
and also come up with a possible
solution with the patient other than
letting him waiting for 11 days shipped
out like a better treatment so we will
not just be able to identify the where a
pathogen with the system you can also
identify a lawful or wherein approach
industry so this is another case coming
from our sequencing user and the paper
was published two years ago in this case
a four year old boy was sent to hospital
with some symptoms with the hand foot
and mouth disease or XPath MD and the
routine solution of the would hinder
losses would be qrt-pcr in this case to
look at whether he is infected with evey
71 or CVA 16 in fact the qrt-pcr says
suggests is actually a pan actually
become infection so
the hospital decided to use our MGI
pathogen fast identification system so
in particular they go for this sample
padlock we've had optimation sequencing
1 and bioinformatics the b-cells is
shown on the right hand side in the
graph here
they were lon overlapping contact back
get back to genome of the pathogen our
first one is human enterovirus c96
and the second one is human portable
bogus number one and the third one is
human coxsackievirus a 24 so ultimately
they also went second sequence with that
the hisab is so here in green and they
match quite well with the
next-generation sequencing data which is
shown here in orange and the PCL we saw
suggest that all the content actually
belong to a consensus sequence to a new
strain which is CV 96 and this is
actually the first time the metagenomic
sequencing used to identify even 96 SS
joined the cause hand foot and mouth
disease which is again something that
not be able to done with even qrt-pcr
and then next case case number 7 is the
identification of co-infection which is
published in 2018 so in this case the
20-year 26 year old woman was sent to
the hospital they have attached she has
a series of symptoms and happy is super
high huncle 44 feet per minute now
they went through a lot of tests it was
negative for bacteria funky color based
test sheet SEM test the on negative and
the hospital staff decided to one and
other series of tests in this case Eliza
qpcr Quixote PCR to detect HIV HPV
inference survivors SARS MERS and other
virus and the results were negative
so what they decided to do is to use a
MGI to my computer solution so she
talked the
they took her pulmonary secretion from
the from the patient collected on the
first day when he was sent to hospital
using this sample to go for the metallic
genomic sequence to determine the cause
here so as you can tell on the white
side the pie chart there were actually
two virus human Y Nova C and the human
vocal virus they were identified as high
abundance using sequencing and these
data or this missile were further
confirmed by a qrt-pcr so and that's why
a report was generated to Dallas to
diagnose it it is an acute infection of
all the virus so basically from this
case I want to point out that with the
traditional memphir you went for all
this test when it's negative that really
is so casing or empathizing the power of
meta genomic sequence because in the
better genomic sequence is no previous
knowledge is required so you don't need
to decide whether you need to do a
culture or what condition of the culture
or Eliza or PCR all you need to do is
just to use the culture theme at a
sample going through the pipeline going
for sequencing informatics to identify
the possible cause of this infection so
in summary I presented seven case using
our BFI or PFI system with our DMP Sigma
copy of detection total solution so by
saying total solution we have a series
of product line from sample path library
path automation and DMDC as well as
powerful by informatics solution BFI
mpfi although there are 20,000
microorganism in the database and we
know there's always not enough and this
why we've been constantly working with
our sequencing user to update our
database for better outcome and as far
as we know our sequencing user or the
total solution user were pretty happy
with the bizarre
not only because they can get the
resolve in a relatively short time
compared to traditional mapper which
take ten days in some of the case that I
mentioned but also because with our
solution they were able to identify the
microorganism there such that they can
screen this for active microorganism and
in a lot of cases from the CDC or
hospital they will actually be able to
use our solution to monitor or sometimes
pee when the epidemic disease outbreak
so with that I would like to thank you
for watching this webinar if you have
any question you can send me an email my
email address is at the bottom left
corner there and if you would like you
could also follow our link in or Twitter
page by scanning the QR code here thank
you so much for listening and watching
thank you